el fuego sigue propagándose con rabia en
Canadá tan solo desde el domingo los
incendios calcinaron 95.000 hectáreas
unas 150.000 canchas de fútbol el martes
se reportaban al menos 86 incendios
forestales en la zona de protección
forestal de Alberta y dos decenas de
ellos estaban fuera de control unos que
han causado la evacuación de miles de
personas y que por ahora no dejan
heridos ni víctimas mortales en este
momento no ha habido heridos reportados
al centro provincial de coordinación de
emergencias Eso no significa que las
autoridades locales no están teniendo
lesiones en el lugar y el seguimiento de
ellos Supongo que lo bueno es que no
hemos tenido ninguna víctima mortal
hasta este momento los incendios dejan
pistas de sus efectos en las grandes
ciudades de Alberta así se veía la
ciudad de calgary el martes la urbe
recibió una alerta meteorológica
especial advirtiendo a los residentes
sobre la mala calidad del aire y la
reducción de la visibilidad debido a las
que produce el clima seco el humo puede
viajar largas distancias en realidad ha
ofrecido algo de ayuda para crear
condiciones más frescas en algunas áreas
a pesar de que el panorama muestra una
leve mejoría el gobierno canadiense
mostraba gran parte de la provincia de
Alberta en extremo peligro de incendio
la situación también ha creado problemas
en la economía del país los precios de
referencia del crudo pesado canadiense
han subido sus niveles más altos en
meses debido a los temores sobre las
conflagraciones